thanks to my patrons for making this
video possible
in the middle of the ocean lies an
island made of trash
1.6 million square kilometers of waste
plastic
sewage wait sorry wrong footage the
great pacific garbage patch is the most
visible example of the plastic pollution
problem in the world's oceans much as we
are polluting the world's air with co2
and other gases we are polluting the
world's oceans with our waste
notably plastics enter team seas the new
project from mark i used to work at nasa
robo and mr capitalism on steroids beast
which aims to raise 30 million dollars
to remove 30 million pounds of plastic
waste from the world's oceans rivers and
beaches now i'm not gonna lie here and
say that we shouldn't be taking plastic
out of the ocean because
well they're full of plastic but this
project is really rather problematic and
i have serious concerns that it could
actually end up doing more harm to the
topic of ocean plastics than good
wait a minute didn't i say this about
the last project from the pair hashtag
team trees
hmm you should probably check the
comments on that
yes i did and i stand by everything i
said in that video but it did seem like
an awful lot of people missed the point
i was trying to get across so this time
around i'll try to be as explicit as i
can videos like this one and my previous
one i think are important because they
form an independent assessment of
projects like team trees and team c's i
didn't get involved with team c's this
year in part so that i could make an
assessment video like this without
independent impartial assessments and
whether you believe me or not this is
impartial we could end up in a situation
where these big projects expend a whole
load of effort and good intentions and
achieve
very little
so this matters and clearly this is a
serious video to accomplish this
assessment with team c's first we need
to put it in perspective in 2015 it was
estimated that there's approximately 150
million tons of plastic in the oceans
and that humans are adding approximately
8 million tons of it every single year
and those numbers are out of date
because the amount of plastic that human
race produces every year has been going
up
oh i can hear the ocean
no that's plastic team seas aims to
remove 30 million pounds of plastic from
the oceans in sensible units that's
about
600 tons which sounds like a lot but not
when compared to the 150 million tons of
plastic in the ocean 13 600 tons is at
most about 0.001
of all the plastic in the ocean in fact
if we assume that eight million tons is
added to the oceans every year again an
underestimate then over the three year
lifespan of team c's removing 13 600
tonnes 24 million tons of plastic waste
will be added to the oceans or to think
of it another way team seas will remove
from the oceans in three years that
which is added in under 15 hours i'm
very cynical probably too cynical about
projects like this
because you see a lot of them and
actually they sound impressive and they
look impressive but when you delve a
little bit deeper into the numbers and
the stats behind it all
actually
their long-term impact becomes quite
questionable this is ellie mclennan a
researcher in certain entanglements
meaning large marine mammals getting
caught in things like fishing gear at
the university of saint andrews she
deals with the impacts of plastic
pollution off the coast of scotland
every day it doesn't even make a dent in
the problem there needs to be much
everything needs to be on a bigger scale
but
the focus needs to be more upstream so
in the actual production of these things
team caesar's impact on ocean plastics
will be minimal but this in itself isn't
a reason to not do the project in fact
the tmc's website says as much here in
the small print it's not a project
trying to be the solution to all ocean
plastics however the major issue with
team seas is that it generates a huge
amount of attention around ocean
plastics which is great but then directs
that attention squarely at trying to
clean up the ocean rather than
systematic changes that would actually
make a difference this is precisely the
problem that i also have with team trees
though i want to be very clear this time
that i'm not saying that the action of
the project is itself bad if i'm laying
here in the ocean covered in plastic and
somebody comes in to help clean some of
it up oh thank you by the way could you
do something about the people who are
just adding the plastic
my concern is with the impact of this
misdirection of attention and how it
will change people's behavior going
forwards in thinking that they've now
done their part by paying for a beach
cleanup specifically now i'm not
suggesting that mr beast and mark have
created this project just to chase clout
and create viral visual content without
seriously consulting with experts in the
field
there's also a very problematic
sociological aspect to this project
where rich countries have to clean up
after developing countries getting
instagram posts along the way without
providing the infrastructure for those
developing countries to help the
situation themselves and actually
dispose of their waste in an
environmentally friendly way which
they want to do lena norms actually just
made a video expanding on this point
which i'll link below if you're
interested more impactful actions would
be things like
investing in technologies or innovations
to produce either less plastic less
virgin plastic biodegradable
alternatives investing in particularly
in developing countries more formal
waste disposal holding producers more
accountable lobbying governments to
actually
make bigger better
faster commitments because i mean
pledges are being made but so many of
them are still voluntary and it just
doesn't work
even if every single
government or industry pledge was stuck
to
it doesn't even make a dent in the
problem there are a huge number of
charities who are already doing this
that team seas could have partnered with
such as plastics for change plastic
pollution coalition and beyond plastics
investing the money in this way would
produce a far greater impact than just
taking some plastic out of the oceans it
could easily stop 13 600 tons of plastic
from being added into the oceans every
single year but unfortunately it's a
little less
visually appealing of course cleaning up
plastics from the oceans is a good thing
i don't want to belittle these guys and
i don't want to say that doing a beach
clean isn't a good thing because you
know who's to say that that bottle cap
that you pick up wouldn't have otherwise
ended up in the stomach of a sea seabird
or that plastic bag wouldn't have ended
up around the neck seal or something so
it's all worth while doing it but
i think these campaigns and these
projects are often badged as a sort of
solution
and they're not they do play a role but
on their own they're they're not
actually making a very big if any
difference at all to stress the crucial
point here let me paint you two possible
futures in one scenario there is no team
seize plastic builds up and builds up in
the oceans and eventually people see
that we need to find a solution they
limit the use of single-use plastics and
they invest in infrastructure in
developing countries so that they can
get rid of their waste in a sustainable
way in the second scenario however team
seas does exist and it removes some
plastic from the oceans about 0.1 of the
total and people feel like they've done
their bit
meanwhile more and more plastic is added
to the oceans but people think i've done
my bit perhaps if i want to fix the
problem i will donate to another ocean
cleanup because that's what we did last
time
and more and more plastic is added to
the oceans and in the end people will
hit on the same solution of stopping the
source of the pollution limiting
single-use plastics and investing in
infrastructure in developing countries
but time was lost and in that delay
more plastic was added to the ocean such
that the total amount of plastic in the
ocean is greater than in the other
scenario this all links back to the
concept of self-licensing that i
mentioned in the previous video people
become overconfident in the impact of
their action via team c's and less
likely to actually take meaningful
action limiting the production of
plastic waste in the future so team c's
as a project could lead to people being
overconfident and mislead their
attention to an ineffective solution but
of course this only becomes a problem if
we let it by putting team c's in context
like in this video and by making the
broader societal problem known that we
produce a lot of plastic pollution a lot
of its single waste and that we need to
widely roll out alternatives and better
infrastructure we can turn team seas
into a broader awareness campaign for
the issue of ocean plastics for example
we could change the emphasis
here without that team sees has the
potential to delay as i outlined in
those two scenarios meaningful action on
ocean plastics and just to explicitly
recap this is because team seas has
raised an enormous amount of attention
and money which is great and then
directed it at a really small amount of
cleanup rather than the widespread
structural changes that are necessary to
fix the problem i think if you've
donated or you've joined in with a beach
clean then that's a really good thing
you've given up you know you've given up
your time where you've given up a little
bit of money to help it's obviously made
you aware of the project and you've been
inspired enough to make that donation of
money or time but i would just
caveat that by saying that's not enough
you know this one-off action it's a step
in a process
but it doesn't work in a silo it doesn't
work on its own so yeah absolutely make
your donation take part of each plane
but don't draw the line there you have
to keep
going
that i don't know why i thought it'd be
anything different
this video was supported by the lovely
people on my patreon if you'd like to
get early access to my videos see some
exclusive content and get access to the
patrons only chat on my discord which is
i won't lie mostly cat pictures then
head to patreon.com simon oxfiz thank
you for watching to the end i'm sure the
comment section on this one will be
totally civil if you enjoyed the video
or learned something from it please do
give it a like and if you think other
people would benefit from seeing it
please do share it on your socials
thanks to ellie for agreeing to take
part in this video if you'd like to
learn more about her research go to
scottishentanglement.org
if you'd like to see more videos from me
then here is some suggested viewing and
that leads me to say thank you again for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one
this is grim